[Music]
Umoja minggu vu o tenganan [ __ ] die foo
that is a well-known Swahili proverb
that means unity is strength division is
weakness at first glance I may not look
like it but I am from Kenya and I've
always been a very proud Kenyan I
represented the country for over ten
years as an international swimmer and
was given the biggest honour of my life
when I was chosen to carry the Kenyan
flag into the opening ceremony of the
London 2012 Olympic Games my swimming
career took me all over the world and
within that many parts of Africa
I visited cities from Cape Town to
Casablanca from Dhaka to doora Salaam
and I always felt incredibly at home in
all of these cities as I was traveling
around Africa and competing who's
fiercely competitive and I wanted to do
everything I could to get my hand on the
wall first and bring a medal back home
to Kenya but at the same time I formed
deep friendships with many of the
swimmers I was up against from just
about every one of the 55 nations
recognized by the African Union and I'm
sure the implications of these
experiences were seated back then and a
big bud began to germinate but it's only
over the last year that I began to
understand their deeper meaning I now
believe will be better for Kenya Africa
and the world if Africa were to become
more United a more United Africa will
mean a more prosperous Africa and will
finally complete the Africa rising
narrative that is being told the world
over and he's in these times of rising
nationalism and isolationism and
different pockets of the world a more
United Africa could just be the
inspiration the world needs for greater
global unity when I arrived at Stanford
in 22
Dean one of the first things I did was
interview for position on the leadership
team for the 10th annual Africa business
conference held here on campus I was
part of a group of students from all
over Africa and not only that all over
the world and we worked hard to try to
put on the most successful Africa
business conference we'd ever had here
at GSB pulled a lot of all nighters and
we ended up putting on one of the most
well attended student organized
conferences in the history of the GSB I
was very proud we were all very proud of
what we had achieved and as I thought
about it you know it again the
implications they didn't really hit me
I'm at Stanford of course I'm gonna be a
part of a high-performing team right
so conference experience done went back
to work out of that experience at the
conference though I started an interview
channel and sat down with some my
classmates run some interviews and many
of them are actually in the audience
today and out of that experience I got
invited to go and cover the Silicon
Valley African Film Festival that is
held every year here in San Jose at the
festival I was part of a group of people
again from all over Africa from all over
the world in fact United and celebrating
the unique cultures of different
countries of the continent but it really
felt that we're all coming together with
one voice in celebration and as I was
running around the conference trying to
source interviews for the red carpet
I bumped into this one man called a you
Baqarah moco as we as I started
questioning him I started to learn a
little bit about him and that he's a
musician martial artist teacher and I'm
asking ways from and he says I'm from
Africa I said yeah most people here are
can you be a little more specific so he
grad grudgingly tells me that he's from
the Ivory Coast and we continued
interview and I'm thinking okay I'm not
sure why he's being so grudging about
this and I asked him you know what what
brings him to the conference and
necessary the film festival and he talks
about you know coming to support
African filmmakers that were there but
also that he's releasing a new album the
name of the album the United States of
Africa act 1 the awakening and looking
back that spoke to a lot of what was
going on for me but I was still
resistant I was a big idea yes but
realistic not so sure came back to
Stanford got back to work and then I
heard that one of my heroes was coming
to Silicon Valley and not just a Silicon
Valley he'd be coming right here to the
GSB to speak on the very stage I'm
standing on right now
his name is strive mass mass c1 for
those who don't know he's one of
Africa's great businessman he's built a
telecoms business that spans the whole
continent connecting people and he
started it with just $500 he was
persecuted under Mugabe regime in
Zimbabwe and against all the odds has
built something quite incredible and I
was part of 20 students they were
actually invited to come and have lunch
with him after he spoke and so we all
assembled in C will boardroom a bass
library to wait for him to enter the
room and as we're lining up he enters
the room and I I put out my hand to
greet him as I always has one always
does and eyes instinctively say so it's
great to meet you my name is Jason I am
from Kenya he doesn't say anything
so we're there holding hands I'm
clasping his and he turns to the rest of
the students assembled and he says I
want you to introduce yourself but I
want you to say you're from Africa and
then tell me your town or city of origin
so I try again my name is Jason I'm from
Africa and the city of Nairobi and now
the synapses in my head were firing out
of control because I had always been a
little offended when people abroad would
refer to Africa as if it were one
country and he was strive Masuya one of
my heroes telling me not to vilify that
kind of thing
but to in fact encourage it and the
challenge he laid out to us as future
business leaders in Africa was clear in
order to drive a more progressive
development agenda we have to become
more United as a complete market Africa
is 1.2 billion people four point four
trillion dollar combined economy
youngest population in the world that is
expected to double by 2050 he said this
population growth could be a blessing or
a curse and it's incumbent on us to make
sure it's a blessing to do that we need
to become more United so more Goods are
used internally increase trade between
the thriving cities that I've been so
lucky to visit and we have to form teams
like I was a part of at the business
conference to lead organizations that
can provide the jobs that will be needed
I'm not to say there's not going to be a
lot of challenges along the way this is
a difficult proposition but it doesn't
mean it's not something we should strive
for I mean it's often times that the
things most worth doing in life are the
most difficult since I last gave this
talk six weeks ago there have been some
developments and 44 African nations have
now signed out an agreement to create
the African continental free trade area
it's a first step and the momentum is
there but we must continue to accelerate
it to get to a United States of Africa
Neera easties id2 vaca Bihari Tokyo
galera pamoja it is easier to cross the
ocean if we're all swimming together
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]